and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 153 Ryan
today we're going to talk about spouses
significant others partners boyfriends
and girlfriends and lovers and any other
noun that I left out of the intro here
awesome man you know I've been thinking
a lot about this because we live in
Southern California now yeah I am a
bunch of different cultures here and I
find myself often when I'm referring to
straight when I talk to strangers about
my partner Rebecca I often refer to her
as my wife yeah and I know you you tend
to do the same thing with Mariah it's it
yeah only if I don't want people to like
dig deeper and what I mean by that is I
just don't have time to explain no it's
not I mean we're technically partners
but we go number five years probably
gonna get may you know it's like going
the whole explanation so yes like to
simplify things I will call her my wife
yeah I ran into someone I was at the
Salt Lake City Airport this past weekend
and someone came up to me and they're
like you look really familiar
she's like what do you do and I'm like
oh what do you do yeah I said what a
horrible yeah and and and and sometimes
like if I want to avoid that question
I'll to say I'm a writer have a nice day
at like like although really like the
thing that broke me of my habit of that
is saying well I'm really passionate
about writing and and to me this is the
the sort of same thing here with with
the spouse thing I we we get into these
titles are important but they're not so
important that we should well it's like
it's with politics you think of someone
I'm a Republican I'm a Democrat I'm a
socialist I'm a libertarian like this is
a set of beliefs or all sometimes a set
of ideologies or whatever but to not
polarize like that like this is a table
that is a label for this I have to label
this thing so we can talk about these
labels
very important to help us identify
whether it's a thing or whether it's an
abstract thing or whether it's a belief
or whether it's a you know a perspective
or whatever it is I mean labels are very
very important I think we get we get in
trouble when we start to identify with
those labels yeah we mean there's so
much weight that they mean everything
the label becomes more important than
the thing itself right like you know the
term minimalism you know I like to say
I'm a minimalist for a lot of reasons I
think that it creates some conversation
I think like you talked about a lot it
is it's kind of the most perfect word
and the most imperfect word right
because it creates a lot of different
reactions when you hear the word
minimalism flailings emotions yeah but
what that does is it creates a
conversation however I wouldn't like
ever just give a response like if
someone gave here here's a present oh
sorry I'm a minimalist wait get out of
here like that would be the wrong way to
introduce minimalism to someone first of
all absolutely it would turn them off
from the concept altogether right and
then and then just you know identifying
with the label that way like really I'm
cut like in that situation using the
label to to kind of as a cop-out almost
right yeah right as if it explains
everything in the label doesn't it it
approximates something they are like I
said it is labels are very good to help
us identify ideas and certain things but
yeah there they are that's just that
they help us approximately identify
something but in at the same time rarely
outside of the these four walls in our
podcast studio shout out to the YouTube
audience hello yo what um you know
outside of these four walls rarely do
you refer to yourself as a minimalist
yeah or a minimalist you're one of the
minimalist yeah you would call yourself
a minimalist if someone comes to you and
says are you a minimalist you're not
gonna say well I'm let me you say yes of
course I am but but it's not it's not
particularly useful all the time however
there are times where it's it's the most
useful label for something and today
when we're talking about these things
I'm going to sort of intentionally sort
of conflate all of these when the
the the catch-all term is sort of
significant other right because that can
mean your wife or husband and it can
mean your boyfriend and girlfriend it
can mean the roommate that you've been
dating for a while it indicates that
you've got someone you've got a
relationship with someone that is a
romantic relationship but even that
label itself is is troublesome to me
because significant is important
significant other or romantic
relationship the significant other okay
because wouldn't even romantic
relationship we could talk about that
but but the significant other because
the person is other like Rebecca in my
life is you could say the other half or
whatever right but it's also it's more
than other it's a union it's together
yeah and so it's not just other and so
there there are problems with with many
of these labels yeah but I found myself
gravitating more and more toward this
term wife and I think the reason being
yeah Beck's and I aren't married we
don't have a set of religious beliefs
that requires us to be married that's to
cohabit that's the best response when
people ask like are you gonna get
married now we're probably gonna get
married why not it's not that religious
yeah well in and then I also have an
aversion to government mandated marriage
too because for so long it's a little
government didn't let certain sets of
people get married because they shared
the same genitalia and it's like well
yet you this these two people have
permission these people don't have
permission and and it's like the
government was was the one mandating who
could and could not be in relationships
basically right but which is weird
because who started that when you think
about the beginning the founding fathers
George Washington was not married
according to the government there was no
such thing as government mandated
marriage license rights back then it was
a covenant and so really what we're
talking about here is a covenant or a
commitment to someone else and does that
require a piece of paper
now Ryan you and I are business partners
and I'm sure we have a piece of paper
that signed somewhere and some file
somewhere but that doesn't that that
means far less that I think contracts
are backward-looking right this is
something from
go and he's written about contracts in
fact podcast Shawn if you can find the
essay about contract he talks about
contracts versus handshakes a contract
looks back and it says you know what
I've been hurt in the past and you know
what I have been hurt in the past I had
a bad marriage and it was bad because of
me I was the one doing the hurting in
the process I was also battering myself
so I was hurt because of me I I picked
the wrong partner for me when we picked
the wrong partners for each other we
figured that out over time
in fact we're much better off now as
friends and we get along really well and
and so I had a wife and with that I had
a negative connotation with that for a
long time with the term marriage or with
the term wife because I was like oh this
this thing called marriage isn't gonna
work for me and what was I saying there
I was telling myself this thing called
commitment isn't gonna work for me yeah
and that was man that was a that was
there was a certain amount of trauma
involved with that and I didn't realize
it at the time but but I had all these
negative associations not just with the
the union between two people but with
commitment in fact before I met back so
I was pretty sure that I was not going
to be in another long-term relationship
like it just wasn't for me and that
that's difficult to realize but then you
also realize like oh maybe that's
because I've been carrying forward some
unnecessary baggage into my present life
so the the contract looks back and it
says well I've been hurt so I'm gonna
sign this contract that doesn't allow
this person to hurt me anymore hmm what
a way to get into a relationship mm-hmm
however a handshake or a commitment
that's what a handshake is right it's a
commitment for the future and and I can
say you know I'm committed to you Ryan
and and our our friendship our business
and and we can shake hands on that we
can hug it out and say I'm committed to
this it doesn't require the piece of
paper the piece of paper itself does not
equal commitment and in fact quite often
the piece of paper gets in the way of
the commitment because we could point
back to that and say
funny man cuz like these questions that
we have coming up on the voicemails it
it actually kind of reaffirmed why I
don't want to get married and I'm not
saying every marriage is like this this
is a me problem yeah
so when I when I get when I was married
I found I don't know I just found it
very easy to care less about the other
person
because for us to split up she was
really gonna have to go through a lot of
work in order to what do you mean and
the real they'd have to get a lawyer
we'd have to we had to split everything
up I mean it was like this process of
breaking vision of assets right and and
it's and it's not like at the time I was
married I was thinking oh she's stuck
with me so I don't have to worry about
doing X Y & Z uh-huh it was this like
sub-conscience complacency that that was
seeping in and and honestly I didn't
even know it until looking back on I was
like oh like that whole like waking up
next to someone and first off feeling
like oh god like I have to be here oh my
god like I yeah I've got to be here and
with the contract we haven't really been
getting along that well but but man I
can't really do anything about it well
she can't really do anything about it
either so it's so it's like it becomes
this complacent feeling it's
disempowering yeah I never want to have
that again man and when I and when I
think about the the the questions that
are coming up some of them at least one
of them to me it seems like that might
be what's happening in the relationship
where you've got one person in the
relationship who really really wants to
do X Y & Z and the other person just
isn't having it and if they weren't
married I guarantee it would be a
different conversation if someone came
to you know if that person can be the
other person said hey I really need this
I need really need x y&z to happen and
they weren't married they're gonna be
like oh okay yeah I really like this
person maybe we're heading towards
marriage one day how what can I do right
now so like really secure this
relationship what what happens you know
five years 10 years 15 years of marriage
you know you oh I really want x y&z to
happen yeah too bad I mean I see that
bad we have this getting through that we
got this
on track I ain't doing that and if you
don't like it then it's gonna take you a
lot of work to get out of this
relationship well that's the what you
said was so profound there with the the
have to I can't believe I have to wake
up next as opposed to get to right and
in the the its contract thinking and by
the way you don't have to have the
contract to have contract thinking
there's some people who are in
relationships who aren't married who
feel like they have to be in it for
whatever reason I have to do this and
that's not real commitment no and and I
can't tell how many times I've heared I
hear people say man if I could do it all
over again I just wouldn't get married I
just wouldn't do it I mean I've heard
people say that a lot of times and if
you know for me if I was in a
relationship especially a marriage and I
was thinking that I might have like oh
if I had to redo it I wouldn't get
married what the hell am i doing in that
relationship so so again
marriage there's nothing wrong with it
it's it's a me problem this is not a
marriage problem as much as it's a Ryan
nicodemus problem and I have to live my
life a little bit differently too to
live a meaningful life and and honestly
like to not get married that that is
more meaningful to me waking up choosing
every day to be with someone rather than
having to yeah commitment is really
birthed out of that everyday willingness
to recommit yeah as opposed to like well
yeah we we we may and by the way you can
do this whether you are married or not
married you're recommit again everywhere
to each other
yeah or you can choose to say well yeah
17 years ago we signed this piece of
paper so the question you disaster this
all over again what is a perfect
question for minimalism in general every
every one widget that we buy every place
that we move every every new
relationship we bring into our life if I
had to do this over again would I and if
the answer is no well then you just
found your new direction in which to
travel yeah yeah I think about Jonathan
friends and he uses the term spouse
equivalent with his with his significant
other
and indexes assured me I shouldn't use
that with us so what is that it sounds
so cold right spousal civilians yeah yes
I mean the thing is I found myself
slowly over time retiring this word
partner and and both intentionally but I
found in order to be more communicative
with certain people when I'm having
these conversations it's using the right
verbage it's using the right dialect to
describe what our relationship is like
and our relationship is much more like
game a marriage than it is a she's not
my girlfriend but I mean I'm approaching
40 years old I'm a bit old to have
girlfriends and at this point but it's a
lot more than just the
boyfriend/girlfriend thanks just a
number man that's just the number yeah
my back
that's so funny man I was I remember
when Mariah and I first started dating
we were having this conversation because
I wasn't comfortable with the word
girlfriend and because is that you
weren't company because it signified too
much commitment or up upfront no for
exactly we just said okay I felt too old
so uh because that's a thing too
especially with younger people like I
can't really call him my boyfriend yet
or my girlfriend is dating because I'm
sleeping with other people right so so I
was explaining to Mariah like hey
exactly what you just said about being
too old for a girlfriend was like I
really don't know what to call it I
guess partner and there was a woman in
the room one of our one of our friends a
friend of Maria's family and she was you
know she's probably 20 years older than
me maybe 15 years older than me and she
was like you know at 30 you find it hard
to you say the word girlfriend she's
like think about it 50 because she was
that you know she dates and stuff she's
like you know 50 I have a hard time
saying boyfriend
yeah and it was right then and there
where I'm like actually I don't care
anymore about the word girlfriend like
because it is it's just an age thing
like it's not that's not the big video
but you know at the end of the day men
at the end of the day at the end of the
day I always say at the end of the day
at night good night Maria at the end of
the day that's the end of the day Mariah
good night no man I mean the fact is is
that I will use the word wife when I
don't feel like some
when digging deeper because I just don't
have the time or you know the mental
bandwidth to explain why a Ryan I've
been partners for five years but yeah
dude it's they I think they are just
labels dude that's all they are they're
just labels at the end of the day no
don't say it no I think I think where
where I'm at with this is what's
appropriate not just for me but for the
situation right and talking about these
things and and really what's important
is not the label itself you know I call
Rebecca Rebecca
in fact I'm probably the only person who
calls her Rebecca yeah everyone else
calls her back saw Rebecca and and
that's the label I give her most of the
time it's just back so Rebecca and and
and for me that's an appropriate label
but what is really important here is not
the label you can set those aside
whatever you're comfortable with use
that label and forget what other people
have have to say about it what is
important is your willingness to be
supportive to be caring to be loving to
be understanding and to show that person
how they want to be shown love yeah and
and if you can do that then regardless
of whether or not you're married or
you've just been dating for a week you
have found this partner the significant
other this lover this person in your
life who who is someone you want to love
and the labels are just just that their
labels well you know it's funny it's got
this aura ring I'm showing the YouTube
audience I just got a yesterday
literally and I had a mood ring it's a
mood ring yes what's your heart mode i
silver floss a black and with a silver
black for you would order is that silver
black it doesn't matter yes
long story short like this is on my ring
finger I chose to wear it on my ring
finger
I got it measured for my ring finger I
Mariah and I intentionally did this as a
symbol so people do understand that we
are in a committed relationship but but
again like that is something that Mariah
and I did that were that was good for us
not for other people but it's something
that we did for the two of us and we
didn't have a ceremony we didn't sign a
piece of paper it just in fact we were
do these rings back in January and she
hasn't got hers yet so
I'm the only one that is symbolizing
that I'm in a relationship that with
several other but right now I just I
want to say that before we dive into
these voicemail questions anyone
listening to this anyone watching this
if you are in a marriage ask yourself
would you do it all over again and if
the answer is yes I want you to take
them I want you to pause this podcast I
want you to take a moment and appreciate
the awesome relationship you have if
you're there in the room with your
spouse pause this podcast give them big
ol hug and kiss because I do love seeing
awesome marriages there are some amazing
marriages out there that like I really I
don't think again I'll ever get married
but there are marriages out there that
that I totally envy and and really
really support people you know who are
and there's also marriages people with
people that you respect and what you're
saying for you is the piece of paper
doesn't matter but what matters is your
commitment to Mariah her commitment to
you and by the way everything is always
subject to change just because you're in
a marriage doesn't mean that that won't
end one day I mean we're the 50% of
marriages in the United States and it's
so messed up dude what 50% of the
marriages and a in divorce
how many mayor how many people are still
married and miserable
how many marriages have ended but the
divorce hasn't happened yet so the
question is like to me is like how many
people are truly happy married it's it's
obviously fewer than 50 percent of
marriages
maybe maybe half of the remaining half
yeah so it's a quarter of marriages
might work I mean we're this is all
anecdotal and we're just throwing out
numbers here but but the reason why
bringing this up to is like the people
who are telling themselves like yeah I
would do it all over again like that you
are in a very very small percent not
very very small but you were into
smaller percentiles you know
congratulations yes congratulations and
keep up the great work
our first question today is from cently
in los angeles me and my husband have a
really hard time talking about money
every time we bring it up he gets very
defensive and it just turns into an
argument and every time we said we're
going to make a budget or do anything
productive with money it never ever
happens and we've been married for
almost two years and as you can imagine
that's causing a big problem I believe
we have to have clarification and
you know just clarity when it comes to
financing especially as a married couple
do you have any tips for a couple making
them budget together so Ron I figured we
might as well turn to the expert on on
finance and marriage with this we were
just on Dave Ramsey show a couple months
ago we were doing the simply southern
tour with with his team yeah down in the
south and then Ramsey they've invited us
on to his show and I mean I can give you
in fact I want to talk about what he
talks about because you and I might
differ a little bit from from his advice
I think it's sound it's a sound
foundation upon which we can we can we
can build our own advice yeah let's
listen to it
Katie is with us in San Diego hi Katie
how are you hi Dave I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up well I'm
just trying to get some advice on how to
get my husband on the same page with our
budget he's kind of more like since when
I don't have any debt and he works
really hard he's in the Navy so he's
kind of like I work hard I don't really
want to be on a budget I work hard and
I'm kind of like I don't care we're
sticking in this budget yeah okay tell
him look I don't care if you work hard
or not you're not a little boy you're
man hey I'm married to a guy that I need
to be a man and a man actually is mature
and plans into the future with his wife
and so a budget is you and I sitting
down together and telling our money what
to do instead of just working our whole
life and then being freaking broke right
okay that's all it is I mean you know
just call him out on his manhood he's in
the Navy come on right and I and I kind
of did calm out but he's just like well
I just feel like we play well you work
for it so you want to end up with
nothing and you want your wife to make
all the decisions I don't want to be
your mother darling I want to be your
wife exactly I feel like his mom
sometimes
oh yeah dadgum right because he's well
so hard I should be able to buy whatever
I want what are you in Congress I mean
seriously this is ridiculous it's just
it's absurd he's just being a he's being
childish and you need to call him out on
that I mean you could do it you can do
it with humor you can do it smart aleck
or you can be real caustic like I'm
being which might not be as effective
actually but but I'm trying to
communicate to you that you're exactly
right and he's out of line okay and so
you need to do you need to lean in on
this how old are you guys I'm 29 he's 30
okay it's time to grow up yeah I agree
yeah you're a real boy now Pinocchio so
let's get on with it you know 430 years
old let's um let's be something right
hey listen a budget does not mean he
can't do anything after he works hard I
worked my butt off I want to buy some
stuff I go along with him on that but
I'm not gonna be irresponsible and have
my wife make all the decisions by
herself and carry all the weight of the
household finances by herself because I
just don't want to deal with it because
I work hard right that mean now you're
he's probably never gonna be a budget
nerd right no absolutely no and I don't
want him to be I'm not asking him to be
that I'm just asking to look at the
situation with you and agree to our
family's goals and what our family's
gonna do and that includes his vote he
gets a vote on this right right so I do
the budget at our house I'm the math
nerd at our house and you know Sharon
and I make the decisions together and
then we both stick to them and then I do
the actual implementation okay all right
all right thank you thank you
so I think part of rephrase anything
Dave said because he said you questioned
his manhood soundly that's all you gonna
do just question your husband's manhood
all right next voicemail I think you
want a question I mean you you want to
show him that he is an adult and you
respect him as an adult and I think
that's awesome what he's saying like if
the tables were turned here I think what
Dave would have said if it was a guy
calling and he would have said in you a
question her womanhood meaning her adult
'no stop and he did say it later on in
this in this conversation with the woman
he said yeah it's time to grow up
basically yeah and I think that's that's
ultimately what he's talking about here
is
grown-up people have a budget not
because it's constraining in a way but
it because it adds certain constraints
that actually allow you to do what you
want to do together the sort of goals of
the family right yeah yeah I mean if I
was suddenly I would I would I don't
know man it's I wouldn't question his
manhood I mean I do agree with Dave
Ramsey and the fact that you do have to
make people mad sometimes to get them to
take action but I think in a in a
relationship especially romantic
relationship attacking the other person
yeah it's definitely not the definitely
not the the best first step but what I
would say certainly is you know ask your
husband what his goals are and then
express to him what your goals are and
you two are gonna have to come to an
agreement on what the family's goals are
I mean Ramsey the one thing that really
stood out is is he said that when it
comes to his finances you know we have
our family's goals if as a couple you
don't have the same goals that's a
problem in fact if you have separate
goals that are pulling you in different
directions you're gonna continue to have
money problems even a bigger problem so
so certainly the first and foremost
anytime anyone asks us how can I you
know what I do with my partner stuff
with finances how do I get my partner
how do I get my mom how do I get my it
is you don't get them to do anything
what you do is certainly you go way out
of your way to support your husband that
is first and foremost you have to show
your husband support you have to show
them appreciation you have to show them
respect and once you show that then you
have taken the first step to create a
very strong relationship and a strong
bond once you have put that work
instantly if you know you're listening
to this right now settling you're like
yeah I've done that I have gone way out
of my way to respect him I've gone wet
on my way to appreciate them and to
support him well that's where you get to
go and ask for support in a very kind
way and again you've heard me say this
probably a thousand times if you've been
listening to us for the last eight years
whenever you're talking to someone
whenever you say the word you it is a
compliment whenever you say whenever you
say the word I that's where you throw
all the naked
stuff on it so what instantly is example
what using certainly has an example she
would say hey you're a really good
husband and you know I really love that
you were in my life I really want to
afford XY and Z in six months or I
really have this goal and I know that
this goal might be a little bit seemed a
little bit daunting but because you're
such a great husband I know that you're
gonna go out of your way to support me
and that should start to get him to see
it your way
you know I'm not trying to jump the gun
here but you know if anyone not just
certainly but if anyone is in a
situation in a relationship where their
spouse is just fighting them tooth and
nail with everything after they've you
know after they've gone on another way
to show support after they've gone out
of their way to show respect you might
want to question that relationship at
the sense of you know where is this
relationship really going I mean they
said she said she's been married for a
couple years so you know obviously like
plenty of time to work stuff out but
your but you and your husband have to
get on the same page somehow yeah well
and so I think the way to get on that
page and you you're actually right you
have to get on this page before you're
gonna be even be able to talk about the
budgeting you know I can give you a
budgeting app and say yeah you go to
every dollar app but she's gonna be the
same position with a better budgeting
tool by herself you go to every dollar
app and she's certainly budging by
herself and her husband is gonna be
spending willy nilly they're not gonna
have their objectives aligned and and so
a few things I'm gonna look at one is
what are your what are your values into
your values match up yeah backs and I
tend to go over our values we just had a
family meeting and we sat down we went
over every single one of our values and
you know I changed this one from last
year and this one is more important to
me now and you know what I realized that
I've I've built up some resentment over
time because of this value is not being
fulfilled and we need to talk about that
and some difficult conversations but you
can have these difficult conversations
and you can even disagree without
arguing or or attacking someone else's
character and or someone's manhood or
womanhood and I I've noticed that that
some quite often there are objectives
like so certainly my guess is you're
gonna go to your husband
he's gonna have some objectives rightly
well the reason I don't want to do a
budget is X Y & Z so there are
objectives but then there are real
issues behind the objectives the
objectives are our surface level and you
can usually get past those so these are
just these are speed bumps someone's
trying to put up to stop you right but
you can get past those what are the real
issues behind those objectives sometimes
it's self-esteem quite often especially
the man in a relationship will often
feel inadequate if there are money
problems in the relationship and and so
does he feel inadequate and that's why
he doesn't want to feel like there's a
budget if so then how can you help him
feel more adequate no I was I think
that's great too I you know maybe she
maybe certainly starts with the question
of hey what is it going to take to get
us on the same page with the budget and
just leave it open-ended mhm and that
will present forth the the objectives
some objectives but you know I'm
thinking about this too man let's it
let's say that you came to me and you're
like hey dude we just moved to Los
Angeles you know it we got to come up
with a budget whatever dude I'm just
like throwing a scenario out there um we
have to come up with a business budget
and I just looked at you and said no
sorry I'm not gonna do that
yeah like how long is that business
relationship gonna last right if you
can't if you can't get on the same page
with money with your romance I mean I'm
not couples isn't always best to work
together so I'm not trying to to say
that if you can't work with your spouse
in the business then you probably should
be married to them that's that's not
what I'm trying to say here what I am
trying to say though is that when it
comes to a romantic relationship you
should be even more willing to cooperate
with that person more than what a
business relationship is and if you
can't talk about money in a relationship
than you shouldn't be in a relationship
absolutely especially in a long-term
committed relationship and and that's
that's important so yeah I agree
so what you're saying Ryan is listening
is key there when you're going and
you're asking the question but then
you're stepping back and saying nothing
you're saying nothing at all you're
simply listening to those objectives and
you're considering those you don't want
to dismiss them but think about each
objective in
important think about what is behind the
objective it might be the self-doubt the
self-esteem issues the inadequacy it
could be fear maybe he has some sort of
fear of well if I start a budget I'm not
going to get X or Y or Z and if that's
the case then how show him how he can
get XY and Z in fact maybe feel more
secure and getting those things with a
budget last thing that I'll say here is
I get defensive when one of two things
happen if I'm offended so if I were to
come to you Ryan said hey we need to put
a business budget together and you like
screw you yeah of course I'm gonna get
the you've offended me right I'm going
to get defensive right by definition
that's when when you start to get
defensive right especially like if you
came to me and was voicing a concern and
being of you know being very kind and
legitimate and it was a legitimate
concern and I just look at you and say f
you yeah now you could also be
postponing you say yeah I don't talk
about that right now that's fine when
should we talk about it let's get a date
on the calendar right now it doesn't
have to be immediately let's get a date
on the calendar next week so that we can
talk about this well recently that's
that's what I would say hey can we sit
down talk about the budget he's gonna
say no I really I want to talk about
right now no problem I totally
understand that I support you in that
you're not in the right mind space in
fact let's give ourselves a week so we
can get in in the right
psychological space to discuss this
without any emotions we're gonna discuss
this very objectively and so how about
next Wednesday we sit down and we talk
about this at 6 p.m. and the other time
that I I get defensive and and this is
when it happens more often than not and
a lot of relationships would certainly
happen with me a lot is when I feel out
of control I feel like I've lost control
now me personally I'm I have control
issues I I know that I'm a bit of a
control freak and letting go of that
control I've learned over the last
several years is the best way to regain
a a different type of stronger emotional
control being willing to let go I mean
it's the reason we work with other
people now I'm not in here running the
cameras by myself because I need to
figure that out we have Joe Nomo over
here Joe Nomo that's the the YouTube
commenters have have given
that that's debrief yeah Joe no Joe no
mo yes we have podcast Shawn we have
Jessica we have Jeff and we have Dave we
have our partners we have all of these
different people in our lives that I
have to relinquish control to right and
so right now Sandy's husband might be
feeling like he has lost control
possibly and so what so what do you need
to do you need to ask yourself how can
you help him regain part of that control
so that together you have control of the
situation also if you're if you're
married you you want to be really open
about your money and you probably want
to combine your money as well as combine
your accounts because as you're doing
that budget if you have two separate
budgets you might as well have two
separate households at that point too
right yeah because he's gonna have his
little bit he's gonna spend it when he
wants to and you have these conflicting
interests but it also means that you
have to agree on your purchases to
certainly and the way that you're
spending money as well part of this
relationship it's it is a giant sort of
US box but in order for you to to
understand what his interests are what
his desires are what he wants to spend
money on he's gonna have to understand
yours but you have to get a real a grip
on your your spending as well and you
have to be willing to put it all on the
table and work on it together I love
that dude like suddenly could totally go
to her husband and say hey I know the
budget has spent something that we've
been trying to get on the same page with
and you know I understand that it's you
know it's difficult because you really
wanna whatever you want to go out on
Fridays and you feel like you're not
gonna be able to do that you know what
I'm gonna go ahead and sacrifice getting
my nails done every other week because I
want you to be able to go out on Friday
so what other things can we do to get on
the same page with the budget I mean
really that's just an example of showing
respect of showing support and
ultimately being kind I think within any
relationship if you can do those three
things like that is really going to
create some meaningful conversation but
we've got to be able to look in the
mirror and say that yes we are truly
shown respect we are showing
appreciation we are showing support for
our partner if you can say that you
truly are doing that
then try to have a kind conversation to
see how y'all can get on the same page
yeah I think one other thing that will
help you especially if you're in debt
I'm not sure if if you're in debt if
you're if you're really trying to create
a budget there there's likely some sort
of debt there Dave Ramsey s of the
called Financial Peace University it's I
think a nine-week program and I think
there's over a thousand of them across
the across the United States going on
simultaneously yeah and what's really
nice about that every tool man is yeah
you can show up you have the materials
but you also have a community of people
there and help that just hold you
accountable but help hold you through
the process guide you through the
process and yeah and and that's
important I gonna put a link to that in
the show notes
I think it's relatively inexpensive like
70 or 80 bucks also podcast Sean if you
can reach out to Dave's team I know
certainly he's in Los Angeles they have
a smart money event it's I think Dave
and maybe Chris who was on our podcast
in January it's down in Irvine in Orange
County it's like a day-long conference
called smart money I'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well we don't
get anything for that I just I think
you'll you'll find some help in that and
if you can give cent Lee a couple
tickets if she's willing to go to that
with her husband I think maybe she'll
find some value in that and then from us
I'd love to give you a copy of our book
essential it's an essay collection with
150 different essays about intentional
living it's 12 different chapters 12
different topics about how to live more
intentionally one of those chapters is
about finances and how you can be more
intentional with your finances with your
budgeting with debt etc so podcast Shawn
if you give reach out to scenter and
give her a copy of essential if you like
the audio book or if you like our
podcast you like the audiobook version
of that or if you want the book book or
the e-book we'll be happy to send those
to you as well I think sent Lee's got
like some really good you know I guess
advice here's some tools that's a better
way of saying it she's got some really
good tools here to use that you've
presented with her presented or her
preferred for her and her husband to use
I guess I'm trying to give suddenly some
hope here like you are you've only been
married for a couple years like it's
still relatively new and fresh
you're still figuring stuff out but if
you have the right tools and put the
effort into it as long as both people
are putting the effort into it yeah
you'll get to figure it out it'll be fun
yes indeed
our next question is from Timothy
somewhere in California I have started
practicing minimalism and I was trying
to follow life of meaningfulness and my
wife really is not into it which is not
a problem because I realize it's
something that I personally want to do
but it really bothers me that I cannot
talk to her about it she every time I
mention it she gets some upset puzzle
like eyes and seeing that I blow of
everything in the wind and so I just
want to know if you have any suggestions
on how I can still continue to practice
life of minimalism without being able to
talk to her about it dude I this
question that Timothy asked just made me
think of something and it's kind of I
guess it applies to both questions but
Mariah and I when we first moved to our
new apartment we were working out there
was this there was a service that is
free at the apartment that we that we
live at I could care less about this
service it's late that it's delivering
groceries essentially you give them like
a list they come once a week and it's
again like at the apartment building
it's a service that they offer it and
when I was like oh this this would you
know might help me out
save me some trips to the store do you
want to sit down and you know go over
this list and we were kind of going back
and forth with it and eventually I got
frustrated and I was like you know what
more I'm like you figured it out
or cancel it like I you know at this
point like it doesn't affect me it's
something that you're interested in I
appreciate you trying to get my get my
input but ultimately you know this is
your thing you deal with it you know she
said to me doing what she made me feel
so bad and by the way that my response
is and like that is not appropriate man
like I'm not perfect I know Josh I've
just crushed my image
with you but I'm not perfect but I will
believe out all the other words that you
use but you know she said to me she said
Ryan I really I really don't feel like
you're supporting me and I feel like
this isn't really a partnership at this
point with with this particular thing
yeah and I guess with senton or with
Timothy you know if you're getting a ton
of pushback to just say something like
man I really was hoping to partner up on
this and I was really hoping to support
one another on this and I feel like I
feel like we're not working together
I really thought you're gonna work
together with me yeah and do when Mariah
said that like it just it helped me see
like oh I'm being a dick and I even
though this doesn't matter to me it
matters to her and because it matters to
her it should matter to me a little bit
yes you know if anything so yeah I
totally like you know just kind of read
a new approach rethought kind of what
what I was doing and what I was saying
and we ended up working out everything's
fine now but yeah just just being able
to take a moment with your partner and
say hey dude you and I are partners hmm
I'm like we are in this life together
and right now and I'll feel that way
yeah and I think reframing is often
really powerful there's a new essay up
on our website right now called would
you be willing to and it's five words
that totally changed my life over the
last five or six years since I've been
using it you notice that we were we were
flying down to Brazil when was this a
few weeks ago I guess and there was this
huge debacle with the tickets they
booked us on the wrong flight in the
wrong seats and yet and and we got to
the calendar and she's like well there's
nothing we can do here and you're gonna
have to do and I just looked at her and
I said hey would you be willing to help
us yeah and she looked at me like well
you can't ask it I understand that but
would you be willing to help us yeah
because the implicit message is there is
hey I know you care mm-hmm and if you
care of course you're gonna be willing
to help me because what's the
alternative screw you no I'm not willing
to help you yet when
asked her that question man it like
exactly what is she gonna say oh no I'm
sorry
I am not willing to like that yeah yeah
yeah it is because what I'm saying is I
I'm actually empowering you mmm because
you might say well I can't and I'm
saying yeah but would you be willing to
uh it's almost in a way saying I believe
that you can I know that you have the
power to I am empowering you with this
would you be willing to help so Sean
maybe put a link to that essay in the
show notes I I those five words you know
if I buy the wrong item somewhere so hey
would you be willing to give me a refund
or I found it for less money somewhere
else would you be willing to help out
with this would you be willing to
because if someone cares they're
unlikely to say yeah well the other
thing to men is like that question the
employee the implicit statement is you
work here uh-huh you do have the ability
to help me right so it's your choice
whether or not you want to help me
exactly and it's worked really well in
in my relationship because instead of
saying hey do this I'm dictate you're
not it's so better than demands it's
more it's more empowering than demanding
it because if hold on to that woman said
no you're going to fix this that might
work in some case no you work here and
you're at the counter you can't fix it
fix it yeah and that's to put yourself
in their shoes what would you rather
hear you and I worked in customer
service for a long time but it's so
funny to me how customers don't realize
that the person that they're asking for
help has the power right so it always
blew my mind when customers you know
came into our cell phone stores and
they're you know throwing phones at us
and it's really yeah and it's like Oh
like not only am I gonna go by the book
on this I'm gonna do as little as I can
for you right because the way you're
treating me right now I'm not going to
reciprocate with niceness going back to
the showing support or showing respect
just respect dude like that question it
shows a lot of respect so with with
Mariah what you maybe could have done in
that scenario is saying hey this is
really stressing me out would you be
willing to take care of this for us
because I feel like this is something
that you'll be able to handle on your
own better than if I were to muck it up
and and maybe just approaching it that
way she
- felt more empowered to do that I
noticed that with backs when when when I
asked her to do something is hey would
you be willing to do blank and whatever
that blank is it's better than saying
hey I'm gonna need you to run to the dry
cleaners a day and do this for me it's
like oh now I'm making a demand and then
what she is she gonna reciprocate later
with further demands of me right no it's
about it's about asking these questions
that are empowering both of us now
here's the thing
Timothy asked how can I be a minimalist
without talking to my wife about it
you can't man well maybe you can are you
gonna hide your minimalism it's gonna be
aware where are you gonna hide it yeah I
mean nothing is impossible right Josh
you don't have anything any of your
stuff no how many stuff to hide your
minimalism under you don't have any
stuff to hide there you go maybe you
hide your minimalism in her stuff here's
the thing communication is key so what
you don't want to hide anything if
you're in a relationship so if you're in
fact I struggle with this personally
because whenever I I get into like well
I've had I've had some health problems
over the last month July and August were
two the best months of my adult life
health-wise I felt amazing and then I
got sick at the beginning of September I
got like this cold and like it stuck
with me and I've had all kinds of
digestive issues and like I've just I
have gotten to like this deep funk i
September was was a bad month for me and
my my natural inclination is to retreat
onto my own because I'm an extreme
introvert and I don't want to be around
anyone so I don't want to tear anyone
else down I don't I don't want to be
negative around you so I just retreat
I'd rather be with myself but part of
being honest and be is being vulnerable
and being it's it's not piling on the
excess of oh woe is me you don't want to
be that you don't want to be oh look at
all my problems but you want to be
honest about yeah I'm struggling right
now and thankfully I have a significant
other a partner in my life who
understands that and is caring and is
loving even during the really try
times and if I couldn't communicate with
her about something whether it was
minimalism or was housing or geography
or values or anything else I couldn't
communicate with her what's gonna build
over time resentment yeah and that
resentment is going to fester and and in
that little that little baby monster in
time is gonna turn into Godzilla and so
you want to address this now or you have
this little baby monster because
eventually you're gonna have so much
resentment that you're not gonna be able
to kill Godzilla right yeah I totally
agree man I mean ultimately the
relationship is gonna be really really
tough if y'all can't support each
other's passions and it sounds to me
like Timothy is passionate about
minimalism so you know Timothy maybe
it's the way that you bring it up I mean
really ask yourself like how are these
conversations about minimalism
minimalism minimal Isabella yeah
how are these conversations how are
these conversations unfolding yeah is it
is it truly like a natural conversation
where Timothy's like oh yeah like I had
a really good day at work today because
I got a lot like clutter cleared from my
desk and I had a really nice day at work
and realize I could you know I could
focus a lot better without all the
clutter mm-hmm
and then you know did she say oh shut up
with that minimalism stuff I mean that's
how the conversation went then then yes
Timothy like you've got to be able to
going back to I told suddenly show your
partner support show them love show them
respect and then ask for some of that
back there are many things that I am
into that mariah is not into I mean her
and I go mountain biking I am way more
adventurous there are certain trails I
don't go on with her because I know that
she's gonna have a bad time I'm gonna
have a good time but Mariah doesn't make
me feel bad about those differences I
mean she will go out of her way to
support me so really the question
Timothy is it's not how how can you you
know have a relationship how can you
have a marriage without bringing up
minimal as
you're right Josh like it it's not
impossible but damn that's gonna make a
really bad relationship yeah yeah and so
when we talk about having a relationship
but why would you want to be in that
relationship at all and so so maybe
she's reacting that way though if she
comes back and he's like saying yeah I
feel great that I got rid of clutter
she's like with that minimalism stuff
again maybe were the problem there is
that that's the objection for her but
the real what's the underlying thing
below the objection maybe she feels
judged yeah how can you show her that
you're not judging her that this is
something that is helping you and then
byproducts is helping your family right
that's absolutely a man because the
other thing I was gonna say is Timothy
are these conversations unfolding in a
way where you know she might say
something like oh I've just you know
I've got a I've got too many shoes in my
closet and and then Timothy comes back
well if you were a minimalist you won't
have this problem yeah maybe that's the
thing maybe she and I've realized as god
I've realized that so much with backs
she doesn't need solutions probably
right exactly you're a man and you're
probably trying to provide solutions and
my guess is because Timothy's calling up
he's actually looking for a solution so
he's a problem salt and offering
solutions is putting blame on the other
person yeah it is judging that other
person it is looking at that person and
saying your life would just be better if
you did this and it doesn't matter if
it's minimalism or if it's religion or
if it's politics if you're talking to
someone and your life would be better if
you just XY and Z that is the worst way
to get someone to support you yeah it's
the worst way to change someone instead
instead of providing her with solutions
provide her with your ear and listen to
her concerns because the only time
you're actually gonna be able to talk
about this minimalism or budget or
anything else is when she feels like she
is in a safe space to talk about it
right now she feels judged and because
she feels judged it feels like a
dangerous place for her she feels
attacked in a way and you're not you're
not intentionally attacking her but even
providing her these solutions that may
have worked for you may not work for her
and so you need to find a way that she
feels safe and comfortable enough to
have this conversation yeah Timothy how
can you show her how invested you are in
the relationship how can you go out of
your way to show her that really the
reason why you choose to live a minimal
life is to is to live a meaningful life
for yourself but in turn that helps the
two of you live a more meaningful life
if she saw it from that perspective it
would be very hard for me to believe
that she still wouldn't support you
again like just don't don't offer her
solutions offer
show her the the benefits I mean it's
what we always say man and offer her
your ear as well yes all right Timothy
I'd love to send you a copy of
everything that remains it's well
there's there's a chapter in there in
particular so it's it's my favorite
thing that we've ever written it's it's
a memoir about our lives from being the
suit-and-tie corporate guys and then
moving all the way over to becoming
minimalist it's this 5-year narrative
but there's a chapter in there about the
us box yeah and that's one thing that
that's going on right now in a lot of
relationships and Timothy's relationship
what's that US box look like Timothy
yeah yeah who's given to that US box and
who's taking right you know so an Us box
and I won't go through the whole thing
there's a long a long chapter about it
and it's probably my favorite chapter in
that book
it's toward the end it's called Harvest
Moon and and in that US box you're
giving to it but you're also getting
from it what are you getting from the
out so every relationship there's an us
box if you're watching on YouTube here
it's right here in the middle the table
I contribute what I can is not always
gonna be 5050 in fact in certain areas
it's gonna be ninety ten in some areas
it's gonna be a hundred and zero because
someone may not be able to give at a
particular season of life yeah and so
you're giving what you can into the US
box and you're taking not what you can
but what you need right Yes Box yeah so
Shawn if you could reach out to Timothy
give him the audiobook version of that
or if you want the book book or the
e-book we'll be happy to send you one of
those as well I just thought of one more
thing man
with Timothy so I know that this comes
up a lot in relationships
I remember the pernicious relationship
you had you knew I liked fancy things
like you were dating that girl who
basically saw the path you were going
down she got upset I were like think you
knew I like fancy things when I was
becoming
yeah than leaving the corporate world
yes so so here's the thing let's say
because I have seen this in a
relationship where one person really
they they love stuff being purchased for
them they really like to get gifts and
I'm not gonna sit here and say the best
Earl of language cuz that's a whole
other type that's a whole other
digression we can I perceive it as their
love life they might perceive it as one
love language so really want someone to
me when someone says that getting gifts
like that's how they are shown love
that's how they feel the most loved it
doesn't have to be physical item one of
the biggest arguments I see when we talk
about love or I'm sorry about
gift-giving not being a language of love
people will say well that's not true my
husband you know he'll clean the house
for me and I really really appreciate
that it's like well yeah that is that
that is showing love it's it's not the
the it's not necessarily the gift as
much as it is the attention it's adding
value to someone's life that's yes so
the question is as Timothy how can you
add value to her life and let's say that
one of the biggest hangups
because I know there's someone listening
to this where this is the issue in their
relationship
one of the biggest hang-ups is where
your significant other let's say
Timothy's wife here really really loves
to get stuff purchased for her well then
Timothy go out of your way to find a
very meaningful thing to get your wife
and that doesn't have to be a ring it
doesn't have to be a bracelet it could
simply be like some concert tickets it
could be like hey honey we're gonna go
watch the sunset together you have to
purchase anything but but showing her
that you still want to fill her life and
show her support show her respect and
you still want to fill her life with
love the way that she perceives it find
ways to do that in Timothy if you do
that brother she absolutely will start
to support you I promise
yes and Dean enjoy that copy of
everything that remains and for those of
you listen to this we'd love to hear
what you have to say so if you have a
comment or a tip about spouses or
marriages or boyfriends girlfriends
lovers including advice for any of our
callers today leave us a voicemail for 0
6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you can also email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm where our favorite comments and
tips on a future episode and stay tuned
to the end of this episode for this week
listener comments and tips Ryan what
time is it it's time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media we're on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram at the minimalists during
the lightning round this is a Ryan and I
each do our best to answer every
question with just a short shareable
less than 140 character response we also
put the text of these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pit the answers on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our quotes in one place thanks to our
good friend Jessica Lynn Williams over
at minimal Maxim's com all our quotes
are over there all right our first
lightning round question is from the mad
hermit sounds like another introvert why
you so mad permit how do you throw out
your spouse's stuff without making them
mad let me repeat that Josh how do you
throw out your spouse's stuff without
making them mad wait wait the mad hermit
is asking this question oh my god
alright so no the mad hermit just needs
to ask themselves oh okay okay so he can
ask himself how can my significant other
throw my stuff out without making me mad
and then just just mirror that with your
spouse yes but if he's a psychopath then
he might maybe he wouldn't care he
wouldn't care but yes I agreed so what
what is it like the golden rule versus
the Platinum rule do unto others as they
want you to do onto them as opposed to
like how you would do it and so yeah
it's a good point well I'll give you a
pithy answer here and then let's expand
on a little bit trashing someone else's
stuff isn't letting go it's theft
literally you're stealing their stuff
and I believe even in a combined
relationship as people have individual
property rights and if better I'm glad
you believe that well I mean there are
many things that Beck's and I own
together mm-hmm
but like my t-shirt if you were to just
go throw this away mm-hmm would be like
why did you throw my t-shirt right right
and if he and then you go throw
something or hers away just to get even
yeah and then that solves the problem
but you'd pick something that meant
little bit more to her just sync it up I
see good one up her a little bit yeah we
continue to escalate so we're throwing
out like I don't know furniture and
setting the house on fire no I mean and
in fact so so we're going through this
exercise right now I getting rid of some
furniture and it really has to do with
with communication and in in in that
communication process oh yeah I was
thinking about this and I really want to
hold on to this I know okay
why do we want to hold on to and notice
the we why do we want to hold on to this
yeah right because it's us it's not well
why do you want to hold on to that thing
no why is this adding value to our lives
best way to start an argument
uh-huh is to say the word you followed
by a judgmental statement yes best way
to start an argument
you love clutter and to keep it going
just keep doing the same thing over and
over again it creates great arguments
yeah which is great for like I don't
know nothing for television maybe yeah
for reality TV yeah but but otherwise I
was still not good yeah avoid getting
rid of your your significant other stuff
and instead talk to them about it yeah
the best way to ruin a relationship is
to try and control the other person so
the mad hermit I would throw this back
on you and say the question is and how
can you throw out her stuff without her
getting mad the question I would be
asking myself is how can I support my
partner the best way I can without
compromising my values and beliefs and
then you approach your partner and you
explain to them hey here's what I am
willing to do because I love you so much
there are a couple things that I really
need help with because I've got this
problem and here are my problems would
you be willing yeah and it may not even
be a problem it could be a preference
right yeah and by the way it's also
listening so in going through that
exercise with backs is saying hey what
why do we find value in this thing or
what why aren't we going to get rid of
this it's truly listening and saying and
it's us having that conversation
together and sometimes we end up at a
different place where she might be like
oh yeah like you know what I don't
really want that or you know what I
thought I needed that or I thought
liked it but not really I mean there's
another new essay that's up on our
website now called well it'll be out by
the time this podcast is out called do I
really want this I've been doing this
with my clothes recently so just
yesterday I I went through a bunch of
like clothes and I started last week and
you know so we got the 9090 rule or
whatever I have I use this in the last
90 days am I gonna use in the next night
but even close the fall within that I'll
pull it off the hanger in the closet and
say okay do I really want this and if
the answer is hell yeah mm-hmm then I
put it back on the hanger because tell
ya what this is I really enjoy having
this shirt or whatever if the answer is
no well then obviously I donate it if
the answer is I don't know if I really
want this mm-hmm
well then I have to wear it within the
next week hmm I have to wear that piece
of clothing within next week so I had
this jacket that I wore last week and I
was like nope
don't really want it like I thought I
wanted it but do I really want it and
after experiencing the item for a day I
was like no I think someone else will
get more value from this and I gave
myself permission to let it go even
though it fell within the 9090 rule dude
I totally this morning I was walking to
work I was like where are those Tom's at
that I had I think you bought me a pair
of Tom's maybe okay and it was it was
back when it was it was a little bit ago
anyway long story short I got rid of him
I'd do anything she's like you don't
hear those I was like oh those but you
know I got here just found my flip-flops
and they're really not that big of a
deal but but yeah man I totally agree
like when it comes to my clothes God
dude like they're all the same so none
of them are really actually these pants
I have on but just about the only hell I
guess that I have just because they're
comfy and I think I think everything you
own is a hell yes though and you you
don't have a whole lot of variety in
your wardrobe so like you're a hell yes
is black t-shirt yeah that's a hell yes
for you a hell yes I'm going to wear a
black t-shirt today it's more like I
have to wear something this is the best
thing I look in so I'm going to wear it
yeah I think it's a hell yes what's our
next question alright our next question
is from is that Louie
Lou Lou my next question is from Lou how
can I figure out the difference between
having a great relationship
and settling for an easy comfortable
relationship this is a good question
yeah it's a great question because
sometimes we confuse the two right we
confuse well this is kind of in fact you
know what man the reason that I know
Beck stayed in her her marriage her and
I were both in eight-year relationship
she was married but before we were
together
and I was married before she was
together obviously and we're both in a
these eight-year relationships and I
think the reason they lasted as long as
they lasted is because they were easy
yeah yeah it's like well I'm following
this trajectory I'm going with the flow
and this is what I'm supposed to do and
so my pit the answer is this easy
relationships atrophy simple
relationships grow a man it's about
making that distinction we're working on
the the soundtrack for our second
documentary right now and one of the
songs was called take it easy and I
asked I asked Nate if he could change
the title to take it simple we have a we
have a essay on our website from years
ago but it's sort of my favorites it's I
accidentally there really like a UPS or
FedEx guy dropping off a package one day
and in Ohio you hear people all the time
so take it easy take it easy it's just
like a you know it's like saying goodbye
right yeah well for whatever reason like
I was something that day I was writing
about simplicity or something and as he
left I said all right take it simple and
I'm like wait a minute what and and ever
since then I've actually signed my
emails would take it simple yeah man
because it's easy is just that it's easy
it's unintentional but simple is
intentional it's deliberate its curated
a forest fire is easy but a beautiful
display of fireworks is simple yeah I
mean for me man to have a good
relationship and needs a couple things
it needs it needs respect and a need
support and you know I don't sit there
and analyze every relationship and list
them out from one to ten okay here's my
here's my most supportive and respectful
relationship all the way to my least
supportive if they include those two
things then I'm usually okay so my pithy
answer is if a relationship is missing
support or
respect it's guaranteed to be pernicious
guaranteed and that's really what I look
at when I look at relationships is is
this a relationship where we both show
support we both show respect
we both are giving to this us box we're
taking as we need and and and that
usually for me means a great
relationship and not just in intimate
relationships either its relationship
with podcast shops luhan's with family
you have to share that support yes in
order for that to grow now now September
for me Ryan has been a hard month and
thankfully I have a simple relationship
with Bex it's not simplistic absolutely
it is not that what you were gonna say
yeah that's not a simplistic relation
right it is intentional and it is
curated but I've had a really hard time
index has been really supportive so I've
tried that so I won't get into too deep
on the the you know if you've been
listening to this podcast for a while
I've had a bunch of health problems last
two and a half years and finally really
dialed them in July and August two best
months of my life because I cut down the
only eating five foods I was eating meat
and greens and coffee and chocolate and
what was the other thing water I think
oh fat like oils that was it and in
September I I started like reintroducing
some some carbs back in because I knew
that long term I didn't want to be on a
full carnivore diet or whatever written
really useful and radically reducing
inflammation but I wanted to bring more
plants back into my life and in doing so
it made me really sick and I've actually
heard this from people I got really
depressed last week man and I'm dude I
don't use that word I don't in fact I
don't think I've ever used that word to
describe my emotions I'm sorry dude when
you call me well yeah I was I mean I
thought the backs about it
well you got someone to talk to ya in
depression is like depression is no joke
dude well I don't depression is worse
than sadness to me Oh way worse yeah in
fact I it's worse than despair like I
felt despair in the past
and the reason I don't use depression
I'll take it lightly as both of my
parents were clinically depressed well
my mother was a depressive my father was
a manic-depressive schizophrenic and so
there's certainly a lot of like family
history with that and I've never been a
person who experiences depression over
the last couple years I've experienced
despair because I'm like man I'm never
gonna heal I've got all these
inflammation problems back problems my
gut problems the c-diff all of these
problems that I had and I felt despair
like oh there's no hope for the future
kind of thing but I never got into this
this crippling depression and there was
a day last week where I'm just like I do
not want to be alive anymore IIIi just
damn dude it was I've never felt those
depths before is it is it a symptom of
everything of the health problems
leading up or was it just a feeling of
like were you depressed because of the
health problems or did the health
problems lead to you all of a sudden
just being depressed does that question
make sense it does I think it was it has
more - it's horrible so bringing these
certain foods back in and with my
certain gut issues that I have it
changed the you know the chemical makeup
of my body and and in doing so it made
things that before would have been
annoying or saddening or frustrating it
them to the point where I felt like
stuck and felt like everything was
pointless and it was a really dark place
to be in I feel like things are
pointless
all the time it's not a depressive
feeling though it's actually kind of a
freeing feeling well about how we give
so many things these meanings but it's
like I'm gonna be dead in 50 years dude
but yeah and that's the problem is I'm
like longer than 50 years why not just
be dead now yeah it's it's yeah and I've
never I've never felt what I felt last
week and it was a combination of certain
things and feeling stuck and and I had
to do with the and the chemical makeup
of you know and so I talked to my doctor
and he's like yeah well go back to what
you were eating and then very slowly
reintroduce things because I was trying
to introduce a bunch of things at once
basically like I'm ready to
start taking back on some of these these
carbohydrates no junk no processed foods
like my diet is pristine but like let's
incorporate some of these things back in
and as I did that like it put me into
this downward spiral and it was really
rough and I'm I'm definitely not all the
way out of it but there was a there was
a period of a week where it was like I'm
feeling like like I there was one day I
looked at best I said I literally feel
like I woke up on the wrong side of the
bed damn it dude I feel like yeah I feel
like just a lot of times you were like
oh my god I've never felt healthier now
you're like I'm so depressed
what and is like in and maybe even more
depressing I'm like oh man maybe I just
should why I'm so stupid I can't believe
I brought these foods back in and I was
feeling so great and now I'm doing this
like I did that I self-sabotage and like
and what I realized cause I was back in
Missoula when this happened I what I
realized is there was there's a whole
lot of trauma that I associated with
with Missoula like really absolutely Wow
because the peak of my health problems
where I thought I was dying member
October 2016 I thought I was dying and
and I every time I go back to Missoula
now I feel there's a trauma attached to
that so I'm reaching out to my therapist
and we're gonna have some conversations
about it I've worked with a therapist
through nourish balanced thrive and
we're gonna have some conversations
about it and trying to better understand
like how in fact I what I love to do
because neither one of us we both of us
have a lot of trauma in our childhood
and and the funny thing is like there's
some things that should be traumatic
they aren't traumatic to me because I
don't associate trauma with it right
yeah but there are other things that
like we can associate like I can't
believe the lights came on in the during
the middle of the podcast and there's
some sort of trauma there yeah and for
me like that's the other thing that made
me depressed being back in Missoula
where I was like this everything is
going great in our lives right now we
just signed the big deal I can't talk
about yet ballet our next big project
that I'm looking forward to sharing with
the world like that was great The Today
Show and megyn kelly are coming out to
our houses this weekend to like film us
and
and I'm back in Missoula this beautiful
place and like all these things I'm like
if I were to like objectively look at
the pro and con list is that my column
of pros is just like everything is great
but I feel this way I feel a completely
in that that actually made it feel me
made me feel more despair like
everything's going really well and I
feel bad yeah and it's not that I even
wanted all of these things to happen or
I think it's not like I was striving for
them as good things are happening
there's always a beautiful place but I
have a certain amount of trauma
associated with that place and I need to
work that out yeah didn't the other
thing to man and you know not they're
opposed dude you were the type of person
that well do one when at the end of 2014
when your health issues really started
to kick in during tour mm-hmm um I think
in a tour I'm like dude like you need to
take a month off and you're like yeah I
need to take a month off and then like
you took the month of December off and I
remember you call him and you're like
yeah I was pretty much gonna kill myself
not doing anything yeah so you are this
type of person who you will fill your
plate up as much as you can mm-hmm and
you know if it's too little you don't
feel good mm-hm and if it's too much you
don't feel good right so it is this
constant balance of trying to because
you just listed off all these pros
that's all we got a lot of pros going on
yeah we got a lot of pros going on huh
so maybe that's something to think about
too is what is there anything we need to
take off our plates man right you know I
mean that might be I don't know no
you're absolutely right and being
willing to let go of any of those things
so that you can and we are arrived yaps
I'm in anything that that's the thing we
say no to so many other like wonderful
opportunities right now like thankfully
we have the vice president of know over
here mr. podcast Sean he's allowed to
say no to everyone for us it makes
things easier for us
hey you have a project you want to work
with the son just send us an email so
podcast Sean can tell you know and it's
not that we don't want to do it she's
gonna have the bandwidth I mean
yesterday
do we get at least one email a day or a
tweet hey I got something I want to work
with you I want to partner up with you
on its right wish I could say yes the
all 400 requests I get a year even even
even with our own team yesterday I mean
Jessica whom
love and she has a bunch of great ideas
I had to say no to her on about four
different things she wanted to work on
yesterday cuz I'm late I just I and it's
just me being honest look I don't have
the bandwidth to do that yeah I would
love to do that I just know that in
order to say yes that I'm going to say
no to something else that I've already
said yes to and so yeah you're right
Ryan we have to continue to reevaluate
in fact there's one thing that we're
about to do right now screen 'la
saturday is a new essay that's on our
website yeah actually the day that we're
recording this but there is so I got
it's funny I got I looked at my email
and saw the the essay came out today I'm
like there's something ironic that was
the point this is our final Hirai
Jessica's putting you've seen those so
on our Instagram account have you seen
that art I've seen art how do you like
it so there's this artist who took these
pictures of people on like whole
families like on their cell phones
either laying in bed backs to each other
staring at their if you're looking at
YouTube you can see me like staring at
their their phone be photoshopped the
photos out oh yeah we talked about this
yeah and so she's posting this on our
Instagram today for Screenland so like
today is the final day on there's three
things you can do with screen las'
Saturday so I'm I'm jumping ahead cuz
we're gonna talk about this during the
right here right now but this
conversations going well so let's just
go with it
yeah the screen low Saturday's is one of
three ways that you can you can adopt
this if you want to join the minimalists
and doing this and I think Ryan and I'll
probably do it differently so for the
rest of the year we're doing starting
October 1st we're doing screen 'less
Saturdays and the way that works is
number one the the social media fast so
the the first step is if you just want
to get off social media Saturday as you
give yourself a break right because the
thing we're talking about here is a
break yeah and the thing I wrote in the
essay is you know a heartbeat is a
heartbeat because it stops the the stop
actually reprobate a generated the same
thing with us in order develop the right
rhythm the the right sync to life and
maybe even our social media life we have
to stop from time to time so step one
if you want to remove yourself from
social media then just do so on
Saturdays you take a little digital
sabbatical on Saturdays or you can do
the the real digital sabbatical where
you get rid of the other the TV and the
computer on Saturdays well closet yeah
you can just hang it hang it up for a
day and it's where our friend Rob Bell
does he avoids those screens on on
Saturdays for Friday night until until
Sunday he just shuts his computer down
and avoids that and then the third step
if you want to get really radical with
it all avoid all digital or all glowing
screens altogether including your phone
now I know most people aren't going to
do that because you want access to the
uber app or whatever I totally
understand that but you gotta call your
mom on Saturday whatever right but why
not at least try it out and even if you
fail you'll probably learn a whole lot
about that experiment so so the question
then is what is the most appropriate for
you maybe just let's hop off social
media for one day a week on Saturdays so
if you're gonna do this with us let us
know you can ping us on Twitter just
just don't do it on a Saturday because
we won't respond yeah we're not gonna
see you can ping us but it doesn't make
any sense you know it's funny because
mariah Nye we're gonna try the extreme
approach mmm just to just to get just to
see how just to experiment you know we
talked about the stoical experiments
that we do right this is one of them but
I know like there are a lot of times
where Mariah and I like will use a
Saturday to like you know veg out on
Ozark or maybe we go see a movie so we
are gonna try the extreme version of it
but we are not going to continue to
deprive ourselves if that's what we find
ourselves doing remember so the
temporary deprivation will help you
learn what's truly adding value to your
life
hundred percent pS Ryan we have one more
question we're gonna answer here
nice James asks how has minimalism
affected your relationships with your
significant others what have been the
positives what were the negatives and
were there any surprises so yes there
have definitely been positives yes there
I've actually been negatives that I
would associate with minimalism and
there certainly have been some
prizes and if you'd like to hear our
answers to that question then you can
listen to this week's PostScript episode
over at the minimalist private podcast
it's available exclusively to our
patreon supporters and if you want to
support our show and keep this podcast a
hundred percent advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes
the minimalist private podcast feed
includes our monthly ask the minimalist
anything episodes unreleased recordings
of our live events and the entire back
catalogue of past private episodes once
you become a supporter you'll receive a
personal link to our private podcast
feed so that it plays in your normal
podcast player you can find all the
details and all the good stuff or over
at the minimalists comm slash support
and here is a snippet from this week's
PostScript episode being intentional it
means you can't put problems off it
means you have to address them in the
moment and guess what that's more
difficult than going with the flow and
pretending the problem doesn't exist
yeah but it's actually less difficult in
the aggregate because you're constantly
dealing with the problems as they arise
okay now it's time for our added-value
portion of the show this is where we
each talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently well you
know I've been listened to a lot of
albums recently but this this new black
album it's called ma'am East Atlanta
Love Letter spelled 6l ACK right right
that's how the kids are spelling black
these days well I it makes sense because
we're in this digital world where for
search engine results you can't just
have in the word black on Google and
you're just gonna get I guess they're
color palettes or like a Wikipedia
description on the absence of light or
something but that's crazy it's just
like one of my other favorite albums I
recommended earlier this year
lovely the band yeah that's real it
early their name lovely the band all one
word oh because they went to Instagram
they're like huh lovely available and of
course it's not because it's one simple
word and so like well let's just
register lovely the band and and that
that's how that became their name they
were just gonna be called lovely hmm but
and and so with with black he is
actually he lives out here and up in the
valley now up in Van Nuys but um he is
from Atlanta and his second album which
man it's it's like this beautiful
minimalist production he and he does
it's it's sort of like R&B but with a
with a hip-hop flair to it for sure I
mean and in fact he is he came from this
this like battle rap scene and then he
started doing R&B songs and there's this
this sort of melding of that but with
this overly simple but aggressively
intentionally simple music behind it I
loved his first album it's one of my
favorites of the last five years
probably my favorite album since black
bear from Andrew Bell it's called free
black I think it came out 2016 and I was
late to the game on that it would have
been my favorite album that year for
sure but yeah this album just came out -
second album and you can tell he's
intentional with every song in fact I
think I'd like to play us out at the end
of this episode with the intro to that
album it's called unfair there's this
lyric in there where he says I don't
want to fight or be at war with you but
you gotta want the same things and
that's really what we're talking
got this whole episode is like look I
want to be your partner I don't want to
fight or we don't need to get into war
together but we have to want the same
things right yeah it's just funny when I
think about all the pernicious
relationships that I've had in my life
and you know all of them being my I mean
I can look at the mirror and say like I
had a lot to do with it I mean for all
intents and purposes my fault um but the
fact that I stayed in those
relationships and kept keeping those
pernicious relationships going it's I
just want to like shake my you know
20-year old self and be like dude what
are you why are you working towards
nothing yeah it's like you all I'm gonna
give it a valiant effort and then I'm
gonna have an exit plan if it doesn't
work
no you're just like well I'm just gonna
keep plodding along at least that's what
I did right yeah so I'll keep plodding
along because maybe someday if I don't
change anything at all and keep going
it's going to magically get better yeah
and it's not the case own adding value
to your life recently well I just got
this aura ring so I'd have the
old-school one yes if we put them
together on camera we become Captain
Planet Voltron oh no electrons more of a
assembly type thing I was taking I was
taking a captain plan it's like the
hearts I've seen Captain America but I
was thinking L to kindergarten the other
day and as I was taking her there like
there was this one kid who was dressed
in full-on Captain America nice weird
were you're Captain America so I said I
had no Captain America goes to your
school she goes yeah that's pretty funny
dude no this is uh I've only had it for
one night I got a sleep score of 58 oh
that is a terrible sleep out of 100 my
readiness is 50 out of 100 terrible I
just can't imagine this is like if this
is how I act and feel on a readiness of
50 I can't wait until you're gonna
change your life I can't I can't wait
until I have like a hundred ready score
I mean I don't know man I do not you
never I woke up I saw my sleeves go I'm
like 50 I was like I feel like more like
I'm ready to go about 75 well so the
readiness score is predicated on a few
things it's your resting heart rate at a
particular time at night
it's your body temperature a nice if
your body temperature was elevated at
night it's also your overall sleep score
your overall sleep score was terrible
now your your sleep score is made up of
a few things one is your REM sleep which
your REM sleep was actually pretty good
last night but your total sleep you
think you had four and a half hours or
something like that now it was really
part of that had to do with you
traveling and stuff yeah it was yeah
it's usually the night after I travel is
pretty bad so so to keep that in mind
also the amount of deep sleep that you
have will radically affect it now
there's certainly things that you can do
to tweak all of these things and that's
what you'll learn over time you'll
develop these patterns and you'll figure
out like oh yeah if I if I do this
before I go to bed or I void late meals
a late meal is going to throw off your
deep sleep scent it's again one of the
biggest for meeting like I get if I
don't go to bed by 9:00 o'clock I am
like starving by 9:30 that's crazy yeah
and so trying to not eat at least three
hours try and do four more if possible
before bed and you're gonna learn a
whole lot so we were saying is it right
I can eat at 9:30 I just can't go to bed
until 12:30 that's right everything well
then it will actually tell you what's
your optimal sleep time tonight a like
oh well it'll start developing patterns
for you like hey tonight it's gonna be
best if you take it easy there in the
den or slow down during the day because
or other days it'll say make sure you're
very active today you're ready to go so
for I didn't really explain this thing
well so the or ring is it just it's like
an Apple watch or like a Fitbit or in
the sleep tracker insert another health
tracker there cuz it's not just sleep I
mean it's sleep it's its heart rate its
exercise its exercise its everything um
body temperature yes for me a tool like
this is it's a good I want to say
motivator or maybe it's good inspiration
I don't know oh it's whichever one there
I think it has what it does for me I can
tell you because I've been using it for
several years now it's a good indicator
of what I need to change and and I make
these these small changes over time
first I made some pretty radical changes
was help which helped me out a lot and
now it's about okay and I wait to look
at it for a while because I don't want
it to influence me so like this morning
I'm like okay
didn't feel like I slept really well I
got him around four and I just I'm not
feeling great but I don't feel terrible
either I think my sleep score is
probably about a 75 mm-hmm and then I
waited a few hours after I did my
morning exercises and I checked it and
it was like your sleep score last that
was 84 I'm like yes it was more yeah you
know it's funny for me like when I sold
a 50 this morning if anything I was like
I'm gonna prove this ring wrong
there you go I'm gonna go I'm gonna be a
hundred today yeah like the best I've
ever seen was Beck's just a few weeks
ago she has one too and she she had a 98
sleep score Wow unlike the most I've
ever had is a 92 I think yeah Anna
something you guys have worked towards
but I mean that's exactly why I got this
man is uh it started off with like the
the step tracker on the iPhone sure and
like that would to me was like okay how
many how many steps have I got in today
have I walked enough of I have I moved
around enough and this is kind of just
it's just taking it to another level
with with kind of keeping track of stuff
now if you do cycling or something you
it won't register it fully you have to
put that into the app but it's real easy
to you hit the plus button hit cycling
and you're good to go
but for walking it tracks like your
steps and it will give you a recommended
based on your readiness for the day so
some days it's like you should do the
equivalent of 300 calories and it'll
show you what that is other days it's
like you should really push your limits
today do 700 and you could do cycling
you can do you know lifting walking
whatever Wow
so yeah I think it'll be really helpful
for you whether or not it's helpful for
anyone else I don't know we're not
recommending it for anyone else but this
is also like the least intrusive for me
it's the besides having my phone on me
with the step counter yeah like this is
the most least intrusive thing I could
find the Apple watches too does too much
alone 800 more accurate than any of the
wrists what's on your finger and so
measure is it better I didn't realize
that yeah it is so it's formed that's
accurate that's really what Mariah
Nyberg
oh yeah like weed because she had a
misfit but it was like it was just she
had to like work on different places to
put it she was like it was it was it was
not it was good it just wasn't great
sure yeah all right let's move on the
right here right now so where we talk
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalist so we're still working on
the second documentary we
we finished the rough cut and what we
learned is we have to go back and we
need to reshoot some scenes we're not
gonna give you the details yet because I
don't want to explain the the the plot
and the sequence of the entire film but
there's some stuff we need to reshoot
and so that might mean it's gonna take a
little bit longer for it to come out
we're reshooting some stuff this month
in October and and and in doing that
we're gonna learn a little bit more
the soundtrack stuff has been phenomenal
the Nate and drew are working on right
now it's oh dude I haven't heard any of
it well send them my way man if you got
some samples yeah for sure
awesome it's unbelievable calls on it
yet but the he's brought in people from
fiction estheban people from several
different my favorite bands that are in
Utah and like they're they're writing
forth are doing strings I mean it's on
the lines Greymon putting together I
can't win on track so we're reshooting
bits of this documentary and when it
will be out I don't know it's like a
documentary we want it to be let's talk
about that dude yeah let's talk about
this project and expectations and
quality yeah so long story short we have
to reshoot a lot of this documentary
that we've already shot right and it's
because when Matt and Josh and I were
looking at this this rough cut mm-hmm
all three of us none of us were excited
about it yeah we all kind of felt the
same way with the aesthetics long story
short we have no expectation with this
documentary this documentary you know my
expectation is with this documentary
what's that well I was gonna say this is
the lowest they could get but I guess it
could probably it lower my expectation
is is that it's gonna go straight to
Vimeo no one's gonna buy it
Netflix no Amazon no Hulu like no one's
gonna be interested in it and we're
gonna send it straight to Vimeo and our
audience is going to we'll sell 10
copies of it I mean like that truly like
that's my expectation I guess the lower
expectation is we're just gonna go ahead
and cancel it which I don't either we're
not gonna do that yeah and I would
actually have a lower expectation than
that because if that were the case I
wouldn't put it out
what do you mean if we were just to say
if we really thought that like only 10
people would get it but then like
clearly I'm right now I could put the
thing out and and the way in its current
state with temp music and and I think
more people will get value from it than
that and so instead I think where you're
going with that is instead of having an
expectation of lay person with views and
with with money and that stuff's
crippling instead it's about having the
highest possible standard we want to be
able to look ourselves in the mirror at
the end of this entire process and
saying hey this is never going to be
perfect mm-hmm but it's going to be the
best that we can do given the finite
resources that we have our last
documentary was great because we over
filmed the thing and then we practice
minimalism and we called the thing
chocolate as much as we could yeah I
mean Matt literally had hundreds of
hours of footage to make a 79 minute
film yeah and guess what we don't have
hundreds of hours of footage for this
one and so what we're doing is we're
going back and we're we have a lot of
footage because we filmed and filmed and
filmed these different talks that we
gave and then we filmed a whole bunch of
other stuff as well so we have a lot of
footage but we need more at this point
so that we can have the right footage to
make this the best possible project and
then where it ends up is irrelevant to
us whether it was on Netflix or YouTube
or on DVD as long as I can look in the
mirror and said this is the best project
we put together I don't care the vehicle
in which it's delivered I want to feel
good I want to feel outstanding about
this piece of art that we're creating
yeah it's the it's the best that we the
feeling that it's the best we could do
with this project where we could start
getting into trouble is if we oh this is
gonna be just as popular as minimalism a
documentary about the important things
that's that's when the expectations come
into play right right exactly man so
yeah I do see what you're saying like
yeah yeah if ii only ten people watch
the film and liked it i mean i wouldn't
consider it a failure but you're right i
mean i guess it isn't really my
expectation i mean what we are trying to
do is create a project that we're really
proud of that's meaningful it's going to
be meaningful and it's gonna add a lot
of value to a lot of people
yeah and you're you're right it's
somewhere between my numbers somewhere
between ten and ten million if we can
fall somewhere in between there I mean I
that the last one was more than ten
million so why don't we do better than
I'm just kidding yeah the the thing that
that I learned through this whole
process of of going through this is what
it's regardless of whether or not it's
gonna be as popular as our last
documentary I want it to be better for
me I want to look at this say okay we
learned these lessons here and so I've
raised my standard and I think that's
part of the reason that all three of us
looked at each other and we were like
yeah we could put this out but so when
he said but it's better for me like I
feel like we've taken the lessons we've
learned from the previous documentary
and feel better about the finished
product no yeah not better about the
content not better about the interview
is not better about the be rolled not
more or less like better about like hey
we've we've learned from this last
documentary now we've got a really
awesome product that or creation that
that we feel great about and yes we've
like carried some of those lessons over
I do not expect like I don't want the
kids when I say feel better like I don't
feel better about it in the sense like
oh this is gonna be better than
minimalism a documentary about the
important things well I do and for me
it's in terms of standards like like the
quality of that last one was great given
the resources we had at the time we've
learned a whole lot so the biggest
resource that we've improved since then
is our knowledge so better-for-you is
quality yes okay yeah yeah so for us we
I mean Matt is leaps and bounds ahead of
where he was oh yeah four years ago
right when you look at his YouTube
channel now he is I mean he's a true
artist and so just the quality of what
Matt has learned and that has raised our
standard you know we get to benefit from
that by proxy but also what you and I
have learned over the course the last
five years our our our knowledge that
that we have developed over that period
of time I want to be able to communicate
that and so this is the vehicle for us
to communicate it's a different message
you know it's about living intentionally
but it's also a lot more personal for us
this documentary is a more personal
piece of work and I think that's the
other reason
I'm like well of course our standard
raises and I the expectation is not that
10 20 30 million 50 million people are
gonna see this thing it's that I've
created the best thing that I can with
the story that we have yeah and I'm
gonna put it out in the world and then
if you enjoy it great there will be
people who find value in it it's up to
you the people watching it is determine
how much value find it and whether or
not you're willing to share this the
other trap that we could fall into is
trying to push something out just to get
it out mm-hmm so the deadline thing yeah
like we were hoping to get this out by
Black Friday right definitely not gonna
well I don't want to say definitely but
probably not gonna happen but unlikely
to how unlikely unlikely that it'll be
out by December 31st but what I'm
getting at is is that if we had this
deadline of Black Friday and that's what
we held near and dear to our hearts
instead of the quality or the meaning
behind this I mean that that is a trap
that people fall into they they give
themselves these arbitrary deadlines
that that even though it's not unfolding
the way that it should be they're gonna
hold to that deadline and those
deadlines can be helpful as long as
you're willing to move them if if
necessary if necessary right and then
the other thing too is due to cost us a
lot of money to film a ton of money the
mo we've ever spent on on a proper
production and it I mean it was it
wasn't I mean it's a ton of money to us
man but my point is is that we could
also look at that and say oh crap like
we just wasted you know ten or twenty
thousand dollars on this production
let's not do that let's go ahead and
stick with what we have because we put
so much time and effort not just the not
just the money dude but like we had a
team like 15 20 people there it's all
their time so like those are questions
to get raised to but you know you Matt
and I we can look at all that and say
hey if that isn't going to be the most
meaningful creation with the the footage
that we have like we've got to look at
that stuff like it is sung costs
absolutely
so yeah just a couple lessons there with
with any of y'all that are struggling
with their creations the quality is is
by the the quality of the of the
creation or you know the high standards
you could look at it that way like that
to us is the most important part of this
creation
yeah and I can't wait to share with you
and as soon as it's available as soon as
we have the best thing that we can put
forward there's some really meaningful
writing really meaningful talks really
meaningful interviews like this whole
thing we found to be really meaningful
we have a really meaningful narrative
that we've created and it's less than 60
minutes and I think you're gonna find a
lot of value in it but we're not ready
to release it yet so we're not going to
until we think it's gonna add the most
value and as soon as we do release it
we're gonna announce our next big
project we've got some really exciting
news probably not gonna be able to outs
it until early 2019 but stay tuned for
that we just we just worked out a deal
on our next project and man you're gonna
be excited about it because I know that
we are and it's it's something that you
all have been asking for for a while and
now we're going to get to share with you
also speaking of previous projects our
our project we decided that the the bag
from our first documentary the packed
bag we put that out last year we we
partnered with Malcolm Vaughn ta we did
this whole campaign about how you
probably don't need another bag and so
please don't buy this you still probably
don't need a bag right now yeah I don't
buy it
nothing has changed probably and you
still need a bag if you do need a bag
it's the one bag that Ryan and I use I'm
just gonna mention this once the the
whole camp of the IndieGoGo campaign is
is done it has its own website now so
you can purchase it if you'd like but be
really intentional if you decide to
bring it into your life don't just buy
it because it's the bag that Ryan and I
use just like don't buy the Rings that
Ryan and I use because those are the
rings that we use but if you if you're
interested it's packed bags calm PA K
tea bags calm we'll put a link to that
in the show notes we'll also put links
to all those essays I mentioned today
screen the Saturdays would you be
willing to and do I want to keep this
and if you want to comment on this
episode you can do so over at
youtube.com slash the minimalists also
on youtube right now we've got some
living room conversations over Ryan's
play some living room conversations in
my place we got some guests on there
we've got
our vlog it's called a meaningful life
episode one is up right now we've got
some house tours coming soon of our
homes and if you want all the podcast
show notes in your email inbox you can
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists com just head there enter
your email address at the top we'll send
you the show notes
anytime we put out a new podcast episode
also any new writings and we'll never
send you any spam because that stuff is
disgusting Ryan you got anything else
for us yeah man it's your favorite part
of the show here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners hi
Josh and Ryan I was listening to your
donation podcast and I recently found a
resource that some folks may appreciate
if you have old jeans lying around that
have shredded or developed holes in
places that are not fashionable you can
actually recycle denim through the blue
jeans Go Green program they collect
donated denim and they turn it into a
housing insulation fiberglass free
housing insulation which is then used by
groups like Habitat for Humanity and a
couple of other builders throughout the
u.s. right now they're partnering with a
couple of retailers through the end of
the year to give you a discount on
buying a new pair of jeans if you donate
a pair so you can check them out at blue
jeans
Go Green dot o-r-g to find out where to
donate and if you would like to organize
a donation drive in your community they
can also give you information about that
hi I'm Kyra coming to you from Corvallis
Oregon and I am commenting on a podcast
donating that the minimalists just put
out and josh had mentioned two places to
sell things online and I just wanted to
offer up Facebook marketplaces and
additional resource to sell things
online Facebook marketplace for me has
been great for smaller ticket items
since I initially had used it to just
get a couple of bucks from some wedding
decorations that we had that we no
longer have use or value for and so I've
also personally sold a lot of items on
both Facebook Marketplace and Craigslist
and so I just want to offer a couple of
pros for a why Facebook and there's a
little bit better than Craigslist as far
as I'm selling this smaller ticket items
for on Facebook you use your
profile and is hooked up to your
marketplace and so for me at least that
offers like an accountable handle for
both the buyers and the sellers so that
way you can view the profile of the
person who's potentially buying
something and they can also view the
profile of you and so this is a better
way to offer less ambiguity that what
Craigslist does and also what another
nice thing is that you can accumulate
ratings on Facebook which is another way
to UM hold you and the buyers or seller
is also accountable it's really easy to
renew items once a week or to keep track
of how long you've had it on Facebook
along with um people and pay you really
quickly through the Facebook app instead
of actually handing over cash which is a
really nice feature that I'm just
learning to use also um you can see how
many views um people have been given to
a certain item that you've put on
Facebook and if you see that you're
getting the views but no one's trying to
make a deal with you you can easily
knock down the price to a more
reasonable one and see um if people will
take the bait there also another really
nice thing that I found with the
Facebook partly place is that um you
really don't get spammed at all if not
hardly uh as compared to Craigslist
which I've definitely gotten in the past
and so what's really nice is that um you
also don't have to give out any personal
contact information all communication
happens through the facebook messenger
you don't be giving out your email your
cell phone number or anything like that
and as far as items I've sold and
include some technology things computer
parts clothes shoes decorations and some
outside equipment it's a super easy
platform and it's really easy to mess up
load a bunch of things I'm going to take
you maybe an hour to upload 30 to 40
items and using your phone directly and
it really doesn't take long at all hi
guys its Leslie a Canadian calling from
London United Kingdom I'm calling to in
response to a caller who asked a
question about giving away baby clothes
and feeling very emotional about it and
just looking for advice on letting go my
case may not be baby clothes but one of
the things I found really helpful was to
think about it in the same way that your
memories are not tied up in the item may
be from a loved one who passed away you
dreams aren't tied up in your items
either and if you decide that right now
you're going to donate those things
they're not a fit for you that's not the
decision to let go of your dream it's to
let go of the stuff and your dream stays
with you and when that dream comes to
fruition you're gonna work hard and put
in place anything you need for it so in
the same way that the decision for to
have a baby it's not tied up in those
baby clothes it's just what it is and
when you're ready to have a baby
I'm sure everything for that baby will
you'll be able to get your hands on it
it'll work out and you'll be able to be
looking at it with fresh eyes all right
you know that's it for this episode if
you have a question or a comment for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm and if y'all live here today with
just one thing we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
minimus